here we go i want to pop i want to
apologize for my face you look like [ __ ]
a little swollen
did you just wake up listen here's a
couple things i need to get through all
right little skull on your sleeve all
right yeah it's a grateful dead logo
it's a great it's
exactly what it is it was the john
varvatos a long time ago it was their
collab
a long time ago this shirt might be
from the 60s we don't know yet yeah all
right
now
i found it hanging in my thing and i'm
waiting for more color you've been
wearing colors
ever since i made fun you've been
wearing color every day but i don't have
anything i don't see anything these are
my old i got green and i got this and
i'm green and i'm really tight on me
though a little tight but it makes your
muscles like pop out i got yeah it's
like daddy doesn't take days off now
when he works out now here's the real
thing wait so daddy was in orlando with
mickey mouse daddy was in orlando now
now see you get older why do you look
like this i'll explain i'll explain
daddy thought it'd be a good idea on a
saturday to do a crossfit workout and
then do two morning uh well i wake up
because it's my
because it's [ __ ] uh uh um
east coast time i wake up at 11 o'clock
right because it's three hours ahead
that's right it's like so now i'm up
because the night before i did two shows
so whatever so i get my seven and a half
hours all i need and i go i got a lot of
energy so first thing daddy's gonna do
is he's gonna go he's gonna do a
crossfit workout so did you look up
crossfit gym and orlando sure didn't i
get the wad of the day and decide to do
that now it's all good i'll push myself
in your hotel room no no down in the gym
okay
okay yeah i'll push myself and i'll do a
little more because what i like to do is
i got an ego and i go you know what i'm
going to do more than push it to the
limit yeah you ever take it easy yeah
the night before i decided to do a
prison house workout which is another
crossfit fit thing 20 minutes you got to
do
five pull-ups on the door jamb 10
push-ups 15 jump squats do that for 20
minutes try to get one round every
minute this is in your hotel that's
going to break yeah that's going to make
you a little sore also when you're over
half a century yeah then the next day
i'm very sore let's push it more so
let's break our body down now let's do
two more shows now you know i'm pretty
physical on stage i'm done
saturday night sure and i'm taking
pictures i'm not doing a meet and greet
i just do it for free i'm just out there
saying hi
so now it's
12
12 15 but it's nine for me i'm still
away
that's the east coast time i can't and
i'm with my our boy louise gomez
hilarious by the way my boy but yeah
yeah okay yeah now you're welcome
goodbye
good guy yeah luis diaz one of us good
guy yeah louis diaz louis yeah monster
right he's monster bro he's hilarious
monster [ __ ] nice guy in the world
great guy beast great guy beast so we go
we we hang a little bit a little drink
so did you did he did he just opened for
you yeah oh nice it was just for him
yeah but i gotta wind down yeah he's a
killer i gotta wind down there he is
there he is he's one of my favorite
people on the planet yeah i told him
nicest guys so nice dude he's cupid he's
cuban i said you gotta do a half hour
you gotta you gotta do a half hour and
put it on youtube and get this thing
going yeah but either way so now i i
[ __ ] uh he's the official cuban thick
boy yes he is
by the way he looks he looks like the
kid from uh up that grew up but in cuba
that's a thick that's that's a good
reference not unathletic uh you know
he's he's got i don't care i don't care
about that do not care
he's a comedian okay let's uh just
acknowledge that he's a funny comedian
because now when i say and i mean i'm
speaking for everybody yeah we don't
give a [ __ ] well we played baseball in
high school well no okay i understand i
just want to say i want to say one thing
now you're strong you're a gorilla yeah
very strong we know this sure
i looked at his legs and hips yeah if if
if he starts getting into some dead lift
but he doesn't want but he does it he
just waits yeah
he used to go ahead no he used to go
heavy he's strong louis you know i love
you you know i love you yeah he's around
he's overthrown
he'll tell you that you ever seen a have
you ever seen a big guy with small
calves no no he's he's hey hold on hold
on you ever seen a big guy with skinny
quads or calves no because what's going
to carry all the weight the legs yeah so
you're basically
leg pressing whatever how much you
weighs every single day so your legs
will be big there you go so wait you
think he's strong just based off looking
at him the kid the kid didn't work out
no spend a lot of time lifting weights i
looked you lived away i take people in i
looked at him i went well you're a
samoan you're a cuban smaller okay i
went you strong guy he goes i am i said
play football he goes i did i said high
school good played one year in college i
guess yeah either way did a lot of
lifting and and it's not it's not hard
for a guy like that if he pulled 600
uh uh i wouldn't be surprised i would
i'd be very surprised yeah but i would
surprise i would and i'm going to say
this
how many times did you see someone call
600
because because the thing is you've
never pulled 600. so the the people
watching this that you can pull 600 is
very very very rare yes so when you
throw around those numbers and you look
like this yeah it drives me crazy okay i
know because now here's the other thing
and i hate to do this yeah yeah you've
never been skinnier you look unhealthy
you're looking i thought the shirt made
your arms look my arms are [ __ ] like
because they're just like sisters just
look thin i've been traveling
whatever it is and i've been
crossfitting and not eating a lot yeah i
thought you gave up on crossfit i did
but why'd you do it again since you've
insulted me i just wanna put some weight
on i just gotta say this you gotta eat i
think all right man just hold on for a
second i'm like your mom where's scarfa
i'm far worse i'm fine
i'm very healthy i got a little i'm
holding a little it's better than you
being big
i'd rather you look like skeletor
hey i'm holding a little weight in my
face right now i'm holding a little
puffiness i'm i'm a little just your
eyes i know dude
i i just want to worry oh dude i'm
putting it on my stomach follow up your
doc have them i'm in the middle of my
story may i sorry do you mind well at
the end of the rep you're talking about
louis diaz playing [ __ ] well and and
i knew you'd get competitive i knew i'm
not in competitive you're very
competitive you're just and you get a
little insecure now listen no no you're
a casual now listen you get a little he
comes around the weight room casual
listen super casual what i'm saying is
this in my opinion and i believe this in
my heart i believe he's he's because
he's a big guy he's stronger than you
are sure do you think he's stronger do
you think he's younger than brendan i do
how did you see this
workout i i i did it
now you saw him in the green room and
realized he had big legs and 300 pounds
and you went oh you're simone because
hold on because i've been around brian
for 10 years every big guy he's ever
seen you you simone leo no
and then and then now you can't do in
2021 you know i can't do it every big
black guy if we're on a plane he goes
would you what are you a basketball
player you're racist that's that's
absolutely
absolutely exactly what do you what are
you getting you're a basketball player
some bars or you rap that's [ __ ]
exaggeration
the guy's like no i'm actually headed to
a [ __ ] you're out of line bro yeah
dude you're out of line i don't say that
i may think it every time i may think
about it i don't say it you just think
everybody's strong listen yes
or they can be oh yeah what is yeah i
don't get the candy i can't even get it
i can't believe you didn't go over his
mom's house to make you a cuban you
can't get a story out that's what you
should have done bro
let him finish the story i know oh wait
so you didn't sleep i don't care how
strong he is i take it i can't admit
he's trying so anyway let's get let's
get beyond him because you get insecure
when i talk about a guy being stronger
than you it's not i get it i agree so
you really think he's strong i think he
pulls over 600 pounds if he really if he
works at it for six months
easily
okay i think he's that strong he's a
casual he's a super casual i know you
have no clue what you're talking about
weightlifting he has no clue i know i
spend time in actual
i i remember i was at venice barbell for
a while i was around you weren't the
power lifter you weren't though you
weren't though i spent some time in
there you weren't though i was there now
i didn't move a lot of weight no i love
that i love diaz is going to listen to
this i'm like what the [ __ ] i about text
him right now he'll be like
what i'll call him i can't pull 600
pounds he he has pulled over he's
baseball player football player
look the kid's very he's a comic and
this is the problem is we don't
acknowledge how great he is at his
career he's great and brian brings up
his high school accolades because he's a
his big legs he's a strong strong kid
okay that doesn't matter i don't know
why yeah so you didn't just knew i
didn't i knew you would i knew you've
been out of high school one thing i like
about getting brendan i can get brendan
riled up so easily i just know this song
no because hold on just around me
because i love him and the only reason
you know of him is because of me you got
all you got all looks insecure and you
started calling me skinny no i call you
not lewis hey don't tell you take your
foot don't put don't put your hand on me
and nobody sees you more than me than
maybe your girl
so i know
yeah well daddy's withering away okay
take it easy i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] my i do
need to do something about my feet i got
some plantar fasciitis or something well
i to get the insole i get the insoles i
gotta eat the answers well your feet are
hurting so did you do it was it on your
heel
no it's where the the tendon meets at
the back of the heel the tip of the heel
yeah so so it's like start wait every
everything like here like because the
tendon runs here and then all connects
there so
i got tension i got tightness here oh
then you'll have plantar fasciitis
i got something going on with my
achilles
oh i don't know i just tight achilles
just tight yeah
wait so so you didn't sleep so what time
is daddy's flight on sunday yeah what
time is it daddy's play on sunday at 6
25 in the morning why would you do that
you've been doing this too long i know
bubba i never do it but that's 3 a.m l.a
direct flight i want to see my kids it's
a direct flight but here's the thing i
used to do the same thing first flight
out [ __ ] well you get there and you're
a zombie your kid's like dude what the
[ __ ] you're doing you feel like [ __ ] but
here's what you feel sick you feel like
[ __ ] but he's not
i get to my hotel room i'm still wired
sorry
what are you doing um what
don't put your face
don't show your shoes off
that's expensive i don't know here
that's oscar's skin isn't it i don't
know all right keep going
tell yourself
i'm not dude go
all right so you're out of flight early
feel sick
you want to be out so i but i make the
mistake of watching the [ __ ]
porter crawford fight that gets me
now i'm wired kind of waste time though
we know it's gonna happen yeah i didn't
i didn't really but yeah
you should call me
great fight
and then i watch um
i want to get your take on his dad
saying what he did but okay keep going
uh and then i watch then i watch the
yair rodriguez holloway fight which i
had missed okay kung fu fest yeah yeah
but i got now it's 2 45 in the morning
and your flight's in three hours
i'm watching fire stop just stay up
sleep on the plane maybe get six hours i
got an hour you know how it is i can't
sleep now because i'm gonna i get
anxiety when i have to wake up that
early i can't sleep i'm gonna sleep and
then i try to sleep sitting up basically
in a plane would my
i was jet blue first class but it's not
funny you can see that you can't sleep
there though yeah guess what it's see
3c
it's [ __ ] there's no there's no first
class
class no they're it's called mint
it isn't even meant i paid the extra
money and it's i swear to god it's i
don't give you comfort it's three seats
you've got comfort yeah i got [ __ ]
pay for comfort so now i can't sleep and
then i get home so i woke up this
morning
at uh you have to make up for it yeah i
woke up at 11 00 this morning
i slept that's late for you that's
ridiculous now that is that is uh was
that 2 p.m in florida time yeah you
slept the day away slept a day away damn
now you're here so here we are
yeah here we are now you made it now now
what questions did you have
wow
we're not oh oh
now dude now
hey christian did you post that who and
i met sean porter and his dad remember
do you remember that yeah watch them
spar yep uh did you po hey uh
chin go to the final kid um
instagram
the fighter and the kid
you're going in on your no not mine i
don't wanna mind
i wanna find a kid the video of brian no
not no not the video the picture of him
uh with the oh yeah it's on the next
tutorial on the story i would put that
on the wall dude
yeah yeah no he just no it's been no
uh posted this morning now i just want
you to see your potential it's on your
story too
you want to see like what i'd look like
with a neck tattoo yes okay let's see
what's let's see what it would look like
[Music]
jay leno
uh-huh
oh
daddy looks sick right oh that's not
that it's not bad now i was younger and
it seems that you don't have that hair
anymore or that beard yeah or that would
take that away take that away but i like
all those dilutions
with italy
look pretty rugged there right i do look
rugged i look scary i post a video so
chris got a neck tattoo we didn't know
he didn't tell us
i'm like kim i don't tell people when
you get tattoos
so he gets it he just sends brian and i
in a group chat a picture of his neck
and i go is that real he goes yeah and
then i've always wanted a neck that do i
love neck tattoo you said sick
i said sick or dope something like that
and then we started talking neck tattoos
yeah we started talking to him for about
a while and then i told chris i said you
[ __ ] up because you put brian on the
screw chat that's right and we're
talking about neck tattoos and shoes and
he's busy getting sun spots taking off
his face and arms
and i put a hashtag oh
i think the next pick has a better there
it is now chris let's not do that
mustache like that because you look
super weird
right
yeah
which is no i didn't he did he goes yeah
it was like 600 bucks which is
nothing for guys like us right brandon i
was like
i couldn't take it i'm listening i'm
watching i'm reading this i'm getting in
an in-depth conversation about a [ __ ]
necktie
oh i don't know what to say there it is
oh god what that must have [ __ ] hurt
on your neck
let's take a break b let's take a break
from chatting with the boys yes now
here's the thing because you know a lot
of our friends have student loans dude
do you know what student loans do to
your future you can be stuck with
student loans for the rest of your life
but you want to you want to pay off your
student loans faster and if you do
ernest
ernest will help you handle your student
debt you could you could potentially
save thousands with refinancing yes
federal student loan payments are on
hold but with rates this low now is a
good time to refinance
you got a road trip a new couch a
savings account if if you could save on
your student loans what would you do
with that extra money dude ernest is
there for you guys manners it only takes
two minutes to see what your new rate
could be there's no credit impact and
right now ernest is offering the firing
kid listeners and viewers 100 cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com fighter not available in all
states once again you get a 100 cash
bonus when you visit earnest.com fighter
to refinance your student loan not a
available in all states terms and
conditions apply earn a student loan
refinancing made by earnest operations
llc nmls number 120 4917 california
financing law license number 605 4788
535 mission street san francisco
california 94105. oh my god visit
earnest.com licenses for a full list of
licenses
earnest.com
fighter listen man
i want my food now do you want it now
and i don't want to have to go and do
all the all the middleman stuff i don't
want to go get in my car i don't want to
do it right now dude want to do this
podcast i just i worked up an appetite
and thank god for my friends at grubhub
because they got us covered man whatever
you need man grubhub works hard to serve
restaurants so they can work hard to
serve you and grubhub is doing some
great deals well like what what i
thought you never asked today grubhub's
doing a little extra to serve panera
that's right get a free delivery perk on
your first order of panera of 15 or more
order through the grubhub app or online
grubhub we serve restaurants
that that picture now bro and i i brian
wasn't responding you're obviously
driving something like that and then we
should get this video from brian i i i
was laughing
i catch up on the thread and i can
barely take it i can't write anything i
gotta make a video
yeah i was so angry i can't even respond
like
my two best friends are basically in
their 40s
you're in your 40 you're 45 brennan
because you're not going to live
both middle aged because neither one of
you are going past 80. one guaranteed so
you're both someone said
neck tattoo is cheaper than eyelid
surgery though
deep
conversation about
i couldn't even take it
i can't even say it you laugh like you
[ __ ]
you might mean chris will happen so all
the energy comes out of my [ __ ] neck
i
i can't because i said i want wings i
want big wings on my neck hey man that
set me off
40. cool
great
i guess it's got significance
and it's got a rose so that's awesome
you've never seen that
hi i mean i
you know
you guys are having an in-depth
you're saying things like sick
that's sick
i've always wanted to get a neck tattoo
this is what's going on in your [ __ ]
head and you send each other pictures of
your [ __ ] shoes
you're 40. over 40 both of you
you too brennan
my head looks good
[ __ ]
both of you [ __ ]
[ __ ] off
get me off this
thread
dude i was doing hold on
go back to that i sent brian this i have
i have the new iphone go to my page i
have the new iphone
it randomly said memories from around
15.
and i was like
right there though
it sent me like seven of them
dude i i was watching i was like did i
pass away
well we had so much fun look at this
[ __ ] and it adds the music look at how
much time passed
[Music]
that's from finding kid 3d we had
something that took me seven years
dude i'm watching it with my girl listen
the [ __ ] music and they put that sad
music
is this song on your iphone did they
know from your playlist automatically
from uh
wow you gotta understand man you and i
have been through an adventure some [ __ ]
we've been that's been a [ __ ] it's been
a journey in so many ways we've been
through some [ __ ] we didn't know what we
were doing here we didn't know what was
going to happen here we didn't know if
it was going to work out we're doing a
sketch show that you know what i'm
saying yeah you know you dyed your hair
remember that
remember all this [ __ ] time that we
had we had so much fun planned for
theaters yeah theaters not uh we
couldn't believe it we were selling
tickets this was the first time anybody
had done a podcast
in a way it's the first time anybody
done a podcast performance like this
yeah like because when you were the
first people to do it live in a way how
we're we're in the hood one of the
greatest times
i mean that was artistic insane dude
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy it was so much
fun and then it throws in like being
born i was like what the [ __ ] are you
trying to do no i'm watching it's all
fighter i
you know i'm not good with emotion i'm
watching it with my [ __ ] girl and i i
had to hide my face because i started
getting yeah i got teary-eyed yeah and
she goes what are you doing i go i was
like this i was like no i'm looking at
this thing you know it's the music
it's the same song when the you know
when they want you to give money for a
landslide landslide by by by stevie
nicks or by complete with mac it's uh
yeah
i'm getting old uh you know it's like
it's about getting older aren't they
crazy yeah
dude those things kill you oh they get
your iphone 5 but but they sent like
seven of them one of just tiger just
boston i was like
what in the [ __ ] is it trying to do wait
is it multiple of those it sent like
seven you can scroll it same song
category no all different songs does it
for you everyone's phone i thought that
was the new name forget you have those
pictures i don't even know what happens
but what's dope you can download it and
i can send you guys so then we all have
it
crazy it's amazing man that was crazy i
sent to my girl because she was
somewhere i was sworn by myself and it
kept popping up because you said
something like this
i got [ __ ] teary or something i don't
know what i know send it to me what
yeah
i'm watching it like that
yeah and i remember we'd be in those
theaters because we did we didn't know
how i was gonna yeah we go on those
theater tours and then remember because
i was always the business one i'd always
settle up with the manager i'd come up
the green room like dude we made eight
grand i know and like split between two
you know yeah it still does yeah but we
were we were like going nuts over that
remember so what you guys were doing
theaters as the pod
or just like or it was like brian and
brendan got it but so
so when we wanted to do to when we
wanted to perform together i wasn't i
didn't have an act so brian was like no
we'll do live find the kids and i was
like yeah but you ever been to a live
podcast or the work like imagine us on
stage in a theater doing this well the
first time i met you all brutal
that was a firing kit yeah that was fun
we had like we those things weren't just
spur of them but we wrote all that yeah
we had a whole separation
yeah yeah call you on the phone is late
so it was like me tricking lions and
always doing stan like i'd be like
calling this his bride come out crowd go
crazy like hold on brian's calling like
dude 10 minutes i'm out here by myself
for 10 minutes yeah yeah yeah people
yeah and brian oh really yeah brian like
just tell them a story and then hang up
and that's how i started doing stand up
that's how i got amazing
crazy yeah but but you also understand
that we would like we would talk about
this too for anybody who's trying to
accomplish anything in life i remember
like you and i i this was my third
podcast i was trying yeah and and
because of the infancy of podcasts we
didn't really know who was listening it
was really hard to yeah
uh
you know uh what's the word like
lucrative like we would and also we
didn't first of all money nobody was
making money on advertising firms it was
just broken i remember rogan was i heard
some of the numbers brogan was making we
were like
what yeah compared to now of course it's
not but but you know what's weird about
that is remember
you and i were doing audio first out of
your garage and then fox sports because
my connection with the ufc picked us up
and they remember fox like and then i
was like hey we need to be on video too
yes and remember so we did we had i
don't know where those episodes are at
our first ones but for two years we just
had audio then went to fox i convinced
them to start shooting it filming it
you ever seen i had no clue at the time
it would have been such a great
negotiation tool at the time you ever
seen the numbers on the videos of the
little fine kids no like with the hodge
twins are you checking like
1.4 million views wow sasso like 800 000
views wow they remember and i'm not
blaming fox they didn't know either no
one knew how to monetize it or that how
it was going that's [ __ ] you so so
when we would pitch on our advertising
it was audio only i didn't sounds like
no one's [ __ ] nobody's watching even
though i want them to do it because i
think this is going to be the future no
we're not like no one's watching because
no one's doing it but then i go back and
look at the views like holy [ __ ] we
should bring in paige so when we he and
i started doing a podcast like this we
didn't know who was listening and i
remember we were talking about how we
both have always just missed in a way
like we've all tried so hard like
you know i was we were successful but
not successful like not not to our
standards like as actors
as athletes as and here we were trying
this thing so when the first time that
we went to seattle i think and and and
even even like we we filled the theater
and they were screaming for us and we
were like
i think and i remember you said when we
had conor mcgregor on the podcast you
said
we you just said you look to me and you
go we just keep doing this yeah we just
keep doing this yeah i know what i mean
because we just keep doing it and then
you were the first guy to come up with
graphics remember you hired a graphic
guy now everybody does it rogan did
everybody copied it but he was the first
guy
to create each other's graphics man
my idea was like a comic book each one
had and i didn't know anything because
we only do it once a week brian post
this so this used to be just once a week
but he would he would hire a graphic guy
yeah and like posters merch i was like
how are you finding these guys i didn't
even know i was never you know he's like
you gotta post you know and remember
we'd have you you'd set up the merch
would go live you'd be like nurture's
gonna go live at five you gotta post now
and i'd be like okay
yeah yeah but it would work we'd sell
out sell out so the the first show you
all did on the road
together like it was a sellout it was
theaters i think you were the first
person with podcasts to do graphics to
do merch and for us to do live shows i
think we [ __ ] crazy yeah and i
remember seeing the checks yeah and i
was like i'm making [ __ ] real money
in the face dude
[ __ ] this and i remember i remember when
uh my age had a tv show for me he i
remember this very well and i and you
said you've been doing this a long time
if you've got to go do a tv show you do
a tv show and i was just like i remember
i said i'm not [ __ ] i'm not
abandoning you because what are you
going to do now we're here together how
the [ __ ] am i going to leave you do it
yeah
and then and then i saw i remember i
said no to that my agent was like he
couldn't understand why we weren't
making that much money but i knew they
said but it was there
they still don't then we started then i
started making money and i remember my
agent came up with another tv show and i
and i heard what the numbers were and i
said this ain't worth it to me dude yeah
he couldn't understand he goes are you
making money on your podcast i was like
remember
remember remember we were in venice like
all your actor friends would
they would like look at me like a meat
head and make fun of me a little bit
behind my back and then they give you
[ __ ] for working with me oh you have no
idea remember that oh no no where that
no they had an intern they were like
that they were like you're for you doing
yeah you're doing this with this some
fighter and you know you and you got you
guys are [ __ ] two kids in a remember
that you guys are two kids in a two
eleven years in a tree house yeah and
you just [ __ ] talk and i remember
that and they were they were making fun
of me behind my back talking about me
and i was just like but we just yeah it
was always a weird vibe i just knew he
was laughing at you
that we just kept doing it so people
were just talking [ __ ] on because it was
but i understand like even my dad was
like what are you doing yeah like
everyone was like what are you doing
that's right the power of this is
is insane you know like i mean look
we've been through a lot man yeah they
tried to kill us i mean i i mean i just
feel absolutely blessed to [ __ ] even
be you're great here with you two guys
right now like i mean i went to spokane
in tacoma to do shows and like there's a
difference because like when i go out
and do weekends like not everybody is
there to see me you know usu like i
don't have that kind of chair you know
pull yet but you know i was doing these
one-nighters at tacoma and uh spokane
and literally everybody was there to see
me yeah based off of like this and then
you taking me on the road with you yeah
it was just it was [ __ ] insane like i
even tried to pull the brendan picture
it's so beautiful i gotta find it but
jump in the crowd like this yeah
but justin took the picture there's a
really bad picture but i mean like i
think you'd be better at it
you think yeah he's always i don't know
people without a podcast like it's uh
here i'll send you crazy um
but
i don't know just like the power of this
and like
people coming up to me and they're like
i love watching you and i'm like what
like it's just weird because i i don't
know i
don't think of myself of any like you
know like high status of anything that's
unspoken but that was yeah that was a
long room
it was cool as [ __ ] you can't see my
face but but still you know like you can
see my teeth and [ __ ] but but i blame
you a little bit because he took it you
could have [ __ ] with the filter to
make it dark so you can see your face
man that was the this mother kyle i said
i said there's a collar oh
but like everybody was there and i mean
there was a line of people to [ __ ]
meet me and i'm just like it's just i
don't know it's just
i don't know it's kind of crazy like i
don't heard it too dude yeah i'm just
thinking about every show you do with me
think about you're in front of thousands
of thousands that's what i'm saying so
you and you do you crush yeah yeah and
then it's that's like you know you're
doing the the well that that's what the
cause we i've done to coma and i've done
uh spokane with you and a lot of people
it came like they're like yo i saw you
open for brent i had to come back you
know like you know look the other thing
about here's what's weird about smoking
i went and you know we're in uh everett
washington this weekend yeah it's like
my fourth biggest market i've never sold
more tickets than a single w right than
spoken wow ever that's like canada
yeah further north you go but you know
like seattle i do well in but it's like
for whatever reason tacoma's spoken i
just for whatever reason i'm going to be
there i can't wait
yeah it just goes i just crushed it then
the new year it's weird yeah that's
great dude i don't know yeah
is this like you know it was really
interesting to me i had i was in orlando
and i had some of the best shows in my
life and i thought to myself because
i've been writing like i've been a
maniac yeah and i thought to myself like
i'm 54 years old and something about
stand-up artistically there's nothing
more fulfilling there's just nothing
more because you created you're one man
you can it's not like a lot of people as
they keep doing things they get less
they're not as good you ever know that
musicians musicians like they have their
heyday in their 30s 20s 27 years yeah
when you're a comic man if you keep
doing it and you're on the road and it
may be uncomfortable but you can be
better than you've ever been in your 50s
and your 60s 100 percent i thought well
the only art so you can really do it
this weekend i thought i would probably
i was like i'm in orlando and
by the way i don't know how you tell
tickets in orlando if you didn't have a
podcast because
that where the improv is with all due
respect the covet killed all the
businesses around it yeah so nobody goes
there there's no traffic so you the only
way to get people is through your
podcast a lot of times
but i just i was sitting there and i
thought to myself on saturday
um it was so satisfying like all the
[ __ ] i've been working on like just the
the time i spent alone trying to work
out that you know you try to work out
the order of things you're trying to
come up with you're carving the jokes
this doesn't work it's a little flimsy
and once it starts
gelling and you're killing that room
yeah is there anything better for real
is there awesome i assume you had to
take shuttles to get to your [ __ ]
rental car i did nothing
i tell you know because jay books all my
[ __ ] i'm like don't book me if the
rental car has a shuttle don't book it
man i'd rather spend the amount of money
than get on that show
more like a loser than a shuttle i can't
oh i'd rather pay five hundred dollars
in a cab [ __ ] i know yeah
you're riding that shuttle you got your
bags
oh my god
[ __ ] you god [ __ ] you and those drivers
they can be rude sometimes takes all the
energy out of my body oh those poor
drivers too they don't want to be there
they don't give a [ __ ] about me they're
like
oh how about j shop a little drinky poos
out in dallas after our show i forgot to
tell you this
you were i don't know if you remember
this you know i'm not
even taking one for the team jay's
driving i'm you know i'm drinking j's
jade barely drinks but you know i have
maybe two drinks still
in the rental car we get like those big
uh sprinter vans so all the boys can fit
in everything yeah we have the sprinter
vans great pulling out
stop sign
goose
heavy i mean i don't mean
i mean
the whole side of the rental car
that's now that's that's gonna be that's
gonna be in the thousands well jacob's
that's that's why i got the full
coverage on it i know yeah
i think
what
i went down
just all knocks
didn't heart rate didn't just kick your
kiss and they kept going
and i go what in the [ __ ] and he goes
what i go do you think i charge him at
the aster i guess that's why i got the
full coverage on it and just keeps going
we haven't addressed it since oh
oh by the way i forgot to tell you
saturday night my last show packed house
in the very back row
chairs start flying
oh yeah i mean a [ __ ] brawl i mean as
in team on team and i'm going like this
i'm trying to stop it it's a racial
thing what was it dominicans no no
that's but you worry about this there's
things that go on but yeah it was just
people get drunk and i guess a girl when
they kept talking the other table was
like shut the [ __ ] up
and then the girl was so drunk that she
well she fell into the other table she
was like
and she was not she had not been missing
any meals sure but that way
she just throw she just falls in the
table everything that's [ __ ] head the
guy the girl throws a punch at the guy
the guy picks up a chair and throws it
at her
yep and now the other now the other guy
so now it's on and i start to [ __ ] up
the whole show guys are you kind of
taping it nobody's listening and i go
kumbaya
did they stop
no they it took them security the entire
staff had to get them out finally so
literally the whole back
gone
rightfully here's the thing though daddy
has
an hour of material on fighting an hour
i mean how much material do you have
fighting that's true that's my thank you
yeah so they think so i what i do if
you're they think you're improving yeah
you went through the old
tools
are we talking fighting and you have 30
years
of how you wish you were a fighter you
got a couple things to say i got a
couple little did they know and it's
been a long time
it's been a long time
oh oh they back the classics i brought
out some of the old songs 104.7
uh it lasted
a good solid five american minutes five
american minutes
right when you hit the stage you're like
no no no this isn't good now this is
probably
35 minutes into my set that now dad did
daddy do the carlos mencia and do a hot
two hours i didn't do that but i had to
get when you reach into the world when
you're reaching to the vault to kiss up
people can't they're like this guy's a
[ __ ] genius how does he come out with
all this stuff they thought it was
important after the show they're all
taking pictures like dude when you went
into that like i wish i was like you
know you just think about that
i mean every by the way everything's
carved out that's good oh yeah those are
my old songs that's rocket man
singing john's rock
bringing up this old hits i got those
notes and it's funny how it comes back
to you like i didn't i haven't thought
about him in so long but it just comes
right back they will once you put that
cassette in and they're weird now i got
to stand i mean i'm standing up there
they were just like wow you know it's a
bag of tricks
yeah anyway it was it was so fun but i
mean it was a brawl and i get this thing
that's
going to pull out a gun or something
yeah because nobody's doing metal
detecting in florida
you understand that everybody in florida
you can carry two blocks right here two
pistols on your hitch yeah so you know
but anyway that is scary yeah yeah it is
yeah yeah but man
did you rent a car and drive from uh
spokane hell no i i flew i flew from
tacoma to spokane i wasn't gonna rent
because because it was uh it was all it
was raining and also snowing and [ __ ] so
i was like how long did like five hours
or something like that is it that far
yeah
jesus
simply yeah wait oh no five hours yeah
no it's because three i'll do it yeah i
like it yeah three hours i would have
done it but like three i'll do five hour
drive and then go do the show but even
even whenever this this weekend on
saturday it's like you fly into seattle
you gotta give yourself time because i
thought
and i know la well i think houston's
worse traffic america la everyone says
bad sure sure i know how to navigate la
traffic these days
seattle because they have to go over
bodies of water well there's rains but
bodies water well they can't open up the
lane so it's you're talking about
two-way like this the traffic's so
[ __ ] remember the last time we were
there you have to give yourself like
three hour notice is that right yeah oh
yeah so because we're staying in seattle
and then driving to everett and however
it is how part about it's uh
40 minutes it says 30 minutes
but i mean you can turn it off yeah it
took us it took us an hour to get to
that's seven miles yeah that's seven
miles
so that's twenty eight twenty eight
miles above 35 so 35 miles you you don't
want to but ever it's a long way if it's
if you got if you got traffic
literally the worst traffic the traffic
was but everett is where uh boeing
headquarters are at
where they make the [ __ ] plane oh you
don't have to say yeah got some money
we're doing a boeing uh i don't think so
i don't care you know that marriage
remember see um seattle it was uh they
had that i can't remember that it was a
pool hall remember it was you ever do
stand up there it was the only place in
seattle after a while uh but it pulled
up it got shut down it got shut down
what was it not not in bellevue uh
bellevue it was about yeah and you had
and you had all these like microsoft
people right
and i did i used to do this joke about
how um i'm funnier than most of the
great men in history right like einstein
even jesus jesus
and i and i talked about how there's not
a lot of room to be funny when you're a
scientist and i go i did something about
creating a clean engine design trying to
get protons stick to a helium isotrope
is like pulling teeth am i right guys
and some guy goes well that's wrong
no [ __ ] i don't even know what i'm
talking about
he's like but protons don't stick to it
he might say get that you get out of
here get out of here that's how smart
though his friends are like what the
[ __ ] it was a whole table of people
yeah doesn't have a
uh a place right now you can just do
theater something weird and it's a great
market you cannot have a club but that
it's like if you do tacoma or spokane
even like everett when they asked me to
do it i'm like was i just in wherever
which everyone's closer spoken in tacoma
and they're like that's like saying
wasn't i just in san diego when you're
playing l.a yeah no like yeah those
people aren't driving down there well
seattle correct me wrong and vancouver
same thing uh are are you can be walking
down the street coffee shop doughnut
shop
and then you make a wrong turn and well
it's it's it's it's the living dead it's
the purge they're all heroin addicts
people are missing teeth they're zombies
walking wait where that homeless [ __ ]
those open air drug markets yeah people
say people say homeless it's drug
addicts it's straight-up heroin addicts
in seattle and uh and i think
it's dicey portland too oh yeah
oh yeah yeah it's crazy i mean there's
bad [ __ ] going on because they don't
enforce it they don't enforce it you see
you you uh you don't criminalize that
kind of behavior and the drug rates well
they they flock there
they know the the laws are loosey-goosey
yeah it encourages it and you know how
they talk about it being the narrative
is it's a homeless problem well the
people that live who who do the services
who are there every day helping those
people they they interviewed those
people they said a homeless problem
the drug the drug addict rate is 100
it's not it's not it's not 99
everybody you see in those tents is it
they are open-air drug markets they are
just doing oh you'll love this be so uh
it came out trump got his uh he's a
ninth degree black belt in taekwondo
yeah well
honorary honorary so they there's a
picture of him and like whoever runs
that there it is so i screenshot that
picture you know my dad hates trump more
than anybody in the world i screenshot
that picture and said to my dad i go do
something
he's like this
even his fist it's like this
i said to my dad go do something you
just didn't respond back
but then i made but then i made his
favorite person on the planet it's jay
leno and then i was with jay leno on
sunday and i sent a picture of the kids
with jay leno right oh your dad loves
jay leno loves jlo loves him that's
[ __ ] hard
yeah jay's always there and he uh he
always has his dope ass cars he won't
shut the [ __ ] up about the plaid tesla
which i won't even entertain what is the
plaid test it's like the it's the fast
tesla like it's so [ __ ] why do they
call it the plaid tesla it's that
version so it's like you know how
there's like a ferrari 48 and there's a
48 p pista a piece that's like the
special like race one yeah plaid's the
race version for tesla and it's so fast
uh rogan has one did you hear um did you
hear that's it right there elon musk is
talking to a bunch of people and he said
um well so far this is a simulation i
hate them though this reality is a
simulation and the guy's like well
what do you mean he goes well this is
all a simulation this could be rebooted
only rich people say that yeah and he
goes and he goes well what are the
chances is not he goes one in a billion
it's a one in a billion chance that it's
not a simulation and then so the guy
says well what do you think and he said
i just told you that's a one in a
billion chance you know he's so yeah i'm
a spectrum yeah i just told you it's one
in a billion chance that it's not it's
not a simulation but it is a simulation
way he thinks what us everything that we
are living is a computer it we are in a
computer program i've heard a couple
people say well you but you've only
heard rich people say that like the guy
at mcdonald's isn't like yeah we're in a
simulation no yeah no
i was like damn i can't wait to get out
this game
but to be fair it comes from
mathematicians for sure they do odds
yeah they're also usually always atheist
as well always really always
that's right always
huh always it's interesting they go hand
in hand yeah
yeah simulation probably living in a
simulation it's really interesting um
what did you say that was in 2018.
although i think
mixes with religion in my opinion like
there is a higher so there's a higher
being a higher intelligence right that's
controlling all this who made that and
we're in a game right again so you
better behave appropriately but but i
won't even entertain simulator are we i
don't [ __ ] know you on twitter
there's two there's too much to think
about no but what are you gonna do yeah
so if we're let's say this is a
simulator where you're just going to
give up you're just going to stop living
what are you going to do well it it it
doesn't bear anything if you have kids
and stuff like that the different dude
yeah for simulation when you have
children yeah he's got kids yeah yeah
when you have children it's it's i
thought about this too when you have
children
i i don't know
i don't care much all i know is i love
that child
too much and i i and i care so deeply
about the world because they're going to
leave they're going to be living in it
after i'm gone correct and so everything
matters to me yeah you want to talk
about you can talk about simulation and
nothing really matters you can do
meditation and
i love this when you do meditation
you're supposed to practice detachment
cool yeah that's great um again a rich
person i'm never going to lose my
desperate attachment to my children and
if if something happens got to also tell
my mom we're in a simulation and to to
disengage and channel while she's
working three jobs with two kids and a
single mom that's what are you talking
about that's right it's only rich people
when you're done when you have to live
in this world yeah oh you'll love this
tiger started skateboarding picked it up
in a day did he really yeah we went to a
toy shop in malibu like when's that
thing solved toy story like straight
like toys r us is gone i'm talking like
toy stores now are barnes and noble on
target they they market they yeah corn
at the market yeah but we're in
melbourne and straight up said toy store
i'm like well [ __ ] let's go in there and
uh tiger was like looking to see and
they found a skateboard i'm like don't
you want a toy i want a skateboard there
he goes and he was like dad uh because
he was watching who's the badass the
young kid right now i guess oh paul
rodriguez yeah he's what he's watching
nigel houston he's watching nigel
houston and p-rod okay and yeah you know
they do all these tricks yeah they were
doing it please dad i learned to do
those tricks i'm like let's learn just
to ride first dude yeah and then he's
falling falling falling dude in a day
that [ __ ] don't do you know what
every day he can skate that's amazing
yeah yeah i'll take him to the party
there's this dope park i go to called
the bear i don't know if he's ready for
like an off-ramp
no his name is a car he said you find a
picture of him in the car
but he's kind of muscular all right oh
yeah yeah no he'd be fine
yeah
is he a little amazing he's a little bit
of a look at that where look at his
calves
look at him oh that picture is on the
[ __ ]
jaylon like anybody in his car but when
it was kids dude look at those cheeks he
let he let the kids all up just [ __ ]
boston stomping on those leather seats
boston is how old now he'll be two
friday he'll be two oh [ __ ]
god that's such a cute age
is he a car freak your son oh big time
he can name all the cars just like i was
like my dad we grew up going to the
denver auto show yeah and then like i
said in our living room had a picture of
a 911 so that was like the goal so tiger
i can they go what car is that team i go
that's a lamborghini aventador what car
is that t that's a porsche gt3 now it
goes the gt3 or gt2 goes you have the g2
that's a gt3 you don't like you don't
like old-school muscle cars like rogan
no he was talking about how sometimes
he'll walk around his car at night
because it just it makes him feel
something that stingray has is i
appreciate them that stingray has you
don't care about you he has a uh
he has a poor i don't know if he posted
he has a porsche 911 that gunther made
that he had tester made
my god
i'll jack off to that car really that's
how [ __ ] bad you're radio uh homie in
denver he he will be yeah willie b [ __ ]
some muscle cars right yeah but not
these vintage porsches it's like dude
it's it's black it's that one right see
that black one
this one the that one yep there it is
really
joe rogan
it's out what is it about that like um
it's so it so that's a uh
it's a 911 it's a old old 911 but they
restore it so it has like all the
current [ __ ] the motor everything you
pick everything down to the stitching on
the steering wheel wow the interior has
these carbon bucket seats it's
stupid that's when rogan said i i'll
just sit in my garage and stare that's
great i'm out and there's there's only
one that's that's the only one really
that's the only one only one in the
world they're not giving that away no no
no no no no no no giving that away
yeah trust much as a house
okay goddamn yeah yeah i mean it's a
beautiful car
with our latest client joe rogan
i'm not sure if joe wanted that out
there like that oh look at that it says
built for joe rogan on it jesus christ
damn that's [ __ ] what he does is
money is exactly what i would do if i
[ __ ] yeah he said because i have [ __ ]
you money so why wouldn't i do what
other people would that's a [ __ ] you car
that car
so you would know that car if you saw
that you'd be like me personally yeah oh
yeah i'd so gunther uh so they make like
they'll make like that's one of one so
you can't buy that car that car's worth
more money than god now but um they had
a gray one my boy greg who i have a uh
business with on cars he brought a gun
through let me drive him he's like
there's only 25 of them because they do
like custom all custom cars so it's just
it's just like a piece of jewelry or
something like a workable yeah i mean
they're so sick dude
and so filthy god damn but what i like
it's just like shoes or anything else
like see that the interior it's art wait
what's going on with the pedal there
that's the that's the passenger side
that's a passionate side
side drive
um and and those are the racing seats
bucket seats and all that yeah carbon
seats damn but what's dope on them is
like especially with uh rogan's like
nobody else will have it or you get a
singer this is a two-year waiting list
like you won't see anybody else with it
ever yeah like you have a gt2 i'll see
other people gt2s but you're not like
they're would you want drive that a lot
oh dude every day what i don't know i've
always wondered what happens if you do
get
like a bumper like a fender bender on
that yeah yeah take you to gunther the
only ones that you can
restore yeah yeah were they based out of
it's so hard gunther gunther's in
l.a pretty sure what's your insurance on
it it doesn't matter at that point
because you have that kind of money no
you think you're wrong you said
huntington beach on one of the po on the
job singers in uh burbank i think oh
honey what's funny is you he could sell
that car because it was made for him
yeah there are collectors that would pay
two million dollars for that car
wait but even if it wasn't joe rogan i'd
say christian bought that car who's not
joe rogan because that's one of one like
you're gonna yeah that car's gonna make
money so in 20 years it's going to be
stupid
yeah
i would do some weird [ __ ] for one of
those cars yeah the weirdest you lie
yeah you're like i'll let everybody in
here run the train on me for sure
if i can design the singer i would
invite you under your nose because that
dilates you're wrong yeah oh wow yep
that's true you know that hit him with
the whenever whenever sam triple is
about to school me on conspiracy on the
podcast he goes he goes i'm going to
give you some poppers right now because
you're in fairy land and you're an idiot
so and then he comes at me he goes take
some poppers
i'm going to be in your ass the whole
time
yep i'm going to hit you with something
when he's on he's not going to be in
your ass he's so funny we got to get him
on the podcast
companion dude we have to he is a
[ __ ] monster hey are you interested
he's so funny he's the best dude he's
the best host
so he came to me he goes you got to do a
podcast with sam triply conspiracy
social club which is now on rockfin by
the
way
he [ __ ] kills me he
he's so funny every time i remember you
said it you know i got him i got it i
got the guy he's gonna so i called sam i
said here's my idea you and kelly do a
conspiracy show you're gonna try and
pitch brian on these conspiracies over
100 episodes he's going to debunk them
yeah that's great and that when we get
into these wwe
[ __ ] you guys go in huh dude over
fouchy he knows this [ __ ] i mean he goes
bad on all these people and he's just
everything is conspiracy and i'm just
like you [ __ ] i used to have to avoid
him at the comment store when i do a
show because he like shoved me and
talked to her oh bro he's like what and
then
30 minutes of
but a deep dive on jfk by the way like
aliens killed jake yeah yeah and then
they're like and he's all shop you're up
you're like oh [ __ ] i've had i've had
the guy who did lose change jason
burma's on the show i've had i've had
every [ __ ] conspiracy guy i've had
the flat earther on the show and by the
way the flat earther was so prepared
he's gonna have your ducks in a row he
hit me with everything and i go like
this i go you know what that's all they
do crazy but you win that's all they
deal with that's his job yeah when on
the internet so many people are like oh
this this so anything you say you better
you better we did the podcast and he had
he showed up with a t-shirt that said
scam democ
and i was like all right i'm already
[ __ ] yeah we have this we have he was
so great and the [ __ ] guy he he i was
like you won you [ __ ] won i'm gonna
give this to you you're crazy and you're
wrong but you still won it was [ __ ]
who's the guys um his name is david
weiss out of his mind but it's his job
it's his job uh-huh that's all they do
oh it's fantastic
are you with ben shapiro what's up if
you're going to argue with ben shapiro
all right about the right yeah you
better have your doctor you better make
ducks in raw because he'll talk so fast
he's also a debater he's also it's like
he's practiced debate he was on the
debate team yes i think at harvard yeah
so that where he went harvard yeah so so
when you when you have a when you debate
a professional debater who's like dude
correct and you're a white belt and
you're like oh i got this and they've
seen it all yeah yeah that's what how
crazy you gotta get triple how crazy is
it with uh rogan though he can't debate
with those guys because he prepares he
prepares he's so [ __ ] scared he's got
his phd
in so many things because he's
essentially reading every book that
these people because for three hours
you're getting what they yeah
thesis so crazy but uh we gotta get
tripley on uh fight companion he's such
a monster he's he just always delivers
what do you think you me sam and chris
oh my gosh because chris and sam know
each other oh my god yeah he'd be a
monster come on he's on he loves mma he
watches ufc used to have mma podcasts he
shows me he shows me a krav maga uh
technique every time he's he studies
krav maga yeah he's so great because uh
and sam is uh armenian he's army you
know yeah yeah he's a super armenian
italian
greatest i love him but are you guys in
town on the 18th i'm in kansas city uh
kansas city improv 17 18 19 but um but
the 11th we're doing it
that's you me and chris and we'll figure
out who else yeah maybe sam we'll see
i think i think the the person that can
hang is either sam or sasso
for sure i'd love to guess that's one
well we'll we'll make that happen yeah
we'll make that happen on fight cecil is
a monster
what is co oh the 18th jake paul i have
bruce buffering
bruce is down jake paul tyson would be a
good one uh no yeah jake paul told me
that's a good one oh jake oh you don't
have logan paul logan's got it
i know that'd be fun right
i learned how to tell justin my age i
was like dude you gotta clear these
dates i'm not i wonder if i could skip
my
it's kind of where's your i like kansas
city though it's a good reason no you're
right you're doing that kansas city
improv yes i'm doing that in february
it's a good market yeah and it's a great
club and i actually like kansas city
dude
great barbecue i like the music i like
the music that joe's barbecue i had
joe's barbecue last year yeah i go
listen to me people get number one
yeah
no one has better barbecue than truth
right truth was yeah they took they took
us under the head like last meal for
barbecue truth truth was amazing yeah
truth pecan lodge is good up in dallas
as well pecan lodge brisket mm-hmm truth
ribs and brisket though
if you have to pick one that was a real
deal right there that was when jay got
the beans spilled on them oh my god it
is a hot
his new shirt beans on his his his like
lewis hamilton shirt yeah it was like it
took like nine weeks to come in yeah
jay's win he's like telling us all about
it and we just sit down because he's
bigger he's a bigger clothe clothing
like horse oh he knows what you should
have seen the pants he was wearing in
dallas yeah he's all in the japanese
[ __ ] yeah oh he'll spend 900 on a pair
of dungarees oh for sure so he looks
like something so he's he's in this uh
brand new like uh f1
so he had he had to get it uh dry clean
so he uh wearing that he's telling us
how like exclusive and how hard it is to
get you know he's balls deep and racing
like oh cool cool the owner of truth has
given us all this food
i'm talking like a family-sized thing of
hot dude hot beans
dude and he goes so what i you know
dude
i don't mean like a splash i mean the
entire
family size style cup of beans hot beans
all on that white shirt
and you know i can tell you know he's my
brother i can tell he's mad jacob's you
know he's not very emotional as [ __ ]
and then the guy and then jj goes give
me some napkins and the guy leaves he
goes i'm so [ __ ] dead
he was in the bathroom i and the guy
gives him a shirt to wear and jason
thank you thank you his face is all
ready you know he goes i'm so [ __ ]
mad
you know what's so funny whenever
anything happens to jay we all get quiet
every time i learned a lesson about
whenever you don't mean myself and irene
results yeah that's jay i learned a
lesson whenever you feel like you look
great when you feel like you look great
and you're you're be careful because the
gods
i learned this lesson a young guy i was
probably 16 and i had my hair my hair
was awesome i had it perfect and i
remember i never and we were out to you
know i was in high school and i was just
like girls and and i was just like this
is going to be awesome and i went to a
boarding school so there was a pizza
place and all the girls would show up
and i liked this girl so much and i had
my shirt and my you're so vain when
you're a kid like that and i was just
like feeling good you want to look good
yeah i look [ __ ] good i remember my
buddy daryl he goes
i don't know why he did this he goes man
shut up i was like shut up and he's
chewing gum anyway
i don't know why he goes
like that thinking i would just pull it
out
he's stuck he's stuck in him
[ __ ] your whole head can't get you can't
get it out once it's entwined now i've
got this
thing it was a big [ __ ] the whole
haircut i had the [ __ ] though i had to
cut him out
because he goes let me [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway and i yeah i had to have
my hair like this after that just be
careful there's nothing like a good hair
day though
like good haircut i haven't had one of
those
but when you have a good hair day it
makes me feel skinny you take really
yeah
yeah i have a good hair day it's [ __ ]
yeah i'm like it's where i do my hair
but when i do it's like it on yeah it's
a process my hair's long yeah it's just
you feel it but how come you can't hit
that every time
that's why like those the hollywood
people like i was watching the amas last
night you know obviously they have uh
stylists and you know
all that [ __ ]
hair stylist everything so they're
making sure it's on point yeah like that
know what the amaze has a bad hair day
well you're doing a press tour like when
you're a celebrity yeah you have someone
like that but you know when you have a
good barber yeah and you know every time
you knock out the part
like i have a guy like that comes the
house yep but it's like if you could
have that every day like those
celebrities well the problem with me is
that i i went to the gym with my buddy
leo flowers now if leo is a
210 pound girl
yeah
yeah so he's a personal trainer yeah so
but when i'm next to him
when i show up to the gym for us to work
out i feel like i'm gonna i look like
him i feel like i
i have the same build i don't know
because we're close yeah he's black and
then we're walking yeah and then we're
walking yeah and i and i look at him in
the mirror next to me yeah and i i
realize how much longer his legs are and
how much
bigger he his body's just better i felt
like a piece of [ __ ] like my whole day's
ruined my whole thing that's why i have
insecurities because i grew up around
you know klopp i'm always compared to
klopp or the lawrence vickers these guys
like yeah i don't have a bad body let's
be real right compared to this i always
that's a disaster yeah nightmare i mean
when you're you're right when you're
next to i remember seeing you
next because i always think of you as
huge and everything else and you would
always say no i remember seeing you
again against aldon smith you were
between alden smith and justin tuck
oh in san francisco yeah at that wedding
yeah i swear to god i swear to god
brendan looked i looked like me he
looked like a [ __ ] he's like i was
like
i thought you know what i thought i
swear to god i went god brennan's like
my size here like he just looked that
dude remember that guy with his shirt
off great player complete [ __ ]
unbelievable body
him he's six foot
four 265 maybe bigger maybe bigger but
like he's taller than you yeah but like
he's about six five yeah
i feel like he might even be six six bob
because he
he was clearly taller than you he's the
jon jones of the nfl craze can't get his
[ __ ] together oh really but an amazing
stupid town so nice stupid town yeah you
tell me thank you that's the best
athlete i remember looking at this yeah
and then justin tuck is a hall of fame
uh defensive end like like change the
game right it's him and michael strahan
yeah yeah freak so you see him he's so
thick him and alden smith next to
brendan and i went yeah i went there i
always tell you this such levels to this
but i always tell you that such levels
to the game you're like then why you say
louise diaz could but have you ever but
that's why i got because i know what
he's going to do but have you ever i say
when i say he's really strong i know
it triggers him because he had to be
around that [ __ ] his whole life yeah i
get it so now when i start saying he can
pull 600 when it took him that much time
to work at it i know how to play him
like i can get him i can get him that's
crazy it didn't take me that much time
oh yeah he got to six deadlifts
you've been lifting your heart
but deadlift is you know i talked to
rappaport who caught me my rib still
hurts yes that's [ __ ] hateful
you can't yeah keep sticking your finger
in the cage
because he's going to grab you and he's
going to squeeze you and he asked for
that all you did was grab him around the
ribs just i said that when shane carter
would pick me up and squeeze me
and he goes this is 40. that dude picked
you up in school yeah well he could do
that to you he could do it if he grabs
you around the room
shane strong and i are big stronger than
brandon so when when a guy like that
there are guys that can pick you up if
you're a regular dude yeah pick you up
and they can squeeze you kill you until
you die now it's a terrible thing to say
out loud and it's a terrible thing for
most men who are proud to walk around
what happens to me what happens to me
every time people meet me in person they
go you're way bigger than thought i
thought
and i'm like i'm taller than you that's
right
yeah shane's [ __ ] shane's stupid
whenever i stand next to you bro i feel
like you're taller than me i am taller
than you
i mean you gotta say like that i'm just
kidding but i'm not just look at him
look at look at look
in the locker room yeah taking the
selfie no the selfie that that would be
the case i can't see you can't see the
bottom the bottom come on that's a dude
who had great genetics who also like
pushed [ __ ] insane that's a crazy
body
that's a christian body
and you used to spar with him
dude his hands are the only guy would go
against that's so weird dude they used
to spar with him and you just got you
guys used to bang oh my god
just hit each other in the [ __ ] head
yep nightmare i don't know look at his
fist i don't know how you did it i
really don't
that that's that was prime
um camelot yeah
dude how about one did he ever fight
kane
no what would that have been like in his
both prime i think he would have gassed
kane wouldn't have gassed he would have
guessed
i mean if he would have connected he uh
it can't be connected he connected with
a [ __ ] horse with anybody yeah he's
knocked a bull out yeah
but yeah the cardio commendation just
kane and kane better wrestler kane would
have had his head in his chest and just
different shane was more explosive shame
[ __ ] tough take down though man
that'd been a good fight yeah
but yeah i think if it if it went into
later rounds it would have been tough
look he was beating the [ __ ] out of
brock but then he just oh they could
have stopped that fight
he gassed all right what do you got
first gin hey b let's take a little
break because you look like you could
use some coffee
i look like coffee
i live for coffee i need energy give me
some coffee what are we gonna do get uh
i gotta get some good beans though
that's the problem i need do you need
good beans man you need good beans
dude you need trade coffee all right and
it shows up
delivered to your door dude that's right
the perfect cup of your coffee all you
got to do is take a short little coffee
quiz all right coffee quick what do you
use use french press yeah automatic drip
yeah cold brew bro cold brew
no problemo
no problemo dude your answers will allow
trade coffee to pair you with the
perfect coffee to fit your taste trade
will match you to coffees you love from
over 400 craft coffee coffees you know
me man i love my coffee they send me new
bags i like the dark roast
freshly roasted yeah traits just for you
man you can feel good too all right
because each cup uh with trade partners
with 55 and more small us-based roasters
who are committed to ethical and
sustainable sources that's important i
want my i want my coffee ethical i want
it to stand i like that chocolate
caramel dark roast that's what i'm about
to do i like my coffee and it tastes
like the way it smells okay too i want
it and apparently your your tastes
evolve and they'll they'll be with you
so listen trade is offering first bag
free and five dollars off your bundle at
out get yours go to drinktrade.com
fighter and use promo code fighter take
this quiz to start your coffee start
your journey to the perfect cup that's
drinktrade.com
fighter promo code fighter for the first
bag free five dollars off your bundle
enjoy your coffee you know me i love
coffee i want it now i love trade yeah
listen man i ha on my mind you like
lebron james i like him do you wanna you
know what makes lebron so great besides
his skills come on
he's common to pressure dude it's he's
getting a lot of sleep dude because he's
calm the number one app for sleeping
meditation phone i have it on my phone
yep and so does lebron yep they he
powered up with calm all right when it
comes to athletes they we we use we just
tend to focus on physical fitness mental
fitness dude you need mental fitness the
number one habit for student meditation
is calm yes lebron and calm know what
the mind is like all right it's just
like any other muscle all right but you
don't have to be a world champion learn
how to train your brain let calm help
you out man for lebron sleep is a
critical part of his mental fitness
routine all right so you go to com.com
spider yep for a limited time you'll get
40 off a calm premium subscription yes i
use this all the time my girl uses it
you have access to the neighborhood you
fall asleep the rain leaves dude
scenes are offended rain or leaves are
amazing you can get everything somebody
can tell you a story yeah that voice you
know is people who talk this way dude
you what should happen is calm should
have you you should have me know one of
your terrible stories so we can all fall
asleep
like a lot of listeners on this show a
long time yeah dude tell us tell a story
on how you came from orlando l.a we'll
all fall asleep all the way from orlando
but i got a lot of soda in my voice
again for a limited time listeners can
join lebron and using com and get 40
discount off a calm premium subscription
at com.com
fighter unlock content to help you focus
ease stress sleep better get started at
fighter that's com.com
c-a-l-m-com slash fighter
that seems like a lifetime wrestled at
asu yeah yeah yeah it's done
so somebody snitched on antonia brown
and said that he actually bought a fake
vax card and turned it into the
buccaneers it turns out that the person
who snitched was his former chef
his uh antonia brown's girlfriend
allegedly went to the chef and said hey
i heard you can get a hold of a bunch of
fake fax cards antonio brown needs one
and there was a dispute between antonio
brown and the chef between like ten
thousand dollars the chef was fired so
the chef snitch on because he owed the
money yeah the chef says that he found
out allegedly that antonio brown got a
hold of a fake vax card and sent it into
the buccaneers the buccaneers are saying
his card actually checks out it's normal
um how are how did you see this vax card
if you guys aren't cool anymore
so people are thinking that the chef is
lying yeah
and then on antonio brown goes [ __ ] i'll
even get the booster shot live on tv
yeah [ __ ]
oh antonio brown said that yeah
what are you doing dude i think it's
just this dispute about uh ten thousand
dollars payment yeah
automotive if somebody's been vaccinated
you can't
they
don't
you could have the antibodies yeah
in fact you have more you have so
how can you well you're saying but
you're gonna it doesn't matter if you go
to a especially in la if you go to store
even though i haven't seen you i've been
all over dude no one's stopped me for a
vaccination but i haven't i have been
i've had i've had it with me at all
times
they never asked me but um
but if you showed it like even if you
can be like oh i had covered two months
ago i have antibiotics they don't give a
[ __ ] you have to prove it right now this
qr code or something there's a database
clear has a thing you can upload your
vaccine card and show like clear for the
airport yeah
they create a whole database
i don't know and and i know tsa is
checking vax cards while you're
traveling this weekend it's the first
time they're doing it really mm-hmm
you just found that out didn't amiibo
i mean i'm vaccinated
i got it
i think they are i won't look that up
jen but
i just traveled yesterday i didn't hear
it but this is how you i think it's this
week only like you can go to your health
app and it has all the information on it
they scare it scan it everything comes
up i think that's the only way you can
prove that you're really vaccinated they
just asked me for the card i showed my
card oh yeah
i'm not at the airport airport's never
asked me i don't know i don't have like
that i had i had to i had the card i
went to an amc the other day and they
said that i had a card and i had this uh
no we need the actual uh
really uh
uh century city mall
[ __ ] did you did you see the [ __ ] did
you listen to rogan's last podcast with
tristan harris and that other guy about
no he's the ethics officer was the chief
ethics engineer for google and he just
talks about how misinformation mal
information like we talk about guns and
all that and being ready for china's
military
that ain't that ain't the warfare you
have to worry about the war the chinese
and the and the russians and other
foreign agents who are able to
create divisions in our country
based on false information radicalizing
our veterans for example who are really
good with violence trying to figure out
a way to do that
civil war yeah not only that you're
pushing people further apart but the
algorithm we know that human beings
tend to
gravitate towards something negative so
if you see a negative article saying i'm
clicking on it you're going to click on
it the problem with that is it happens
automatically and it just keeps pushing
it well so the algorithm on youtube and
facebook does that automatically right
so it keeps pushing people farther and
farther apart but now china is starting
to see that so with china because they
can do [ __ ] china goes like this no but
china goes for their they go if you're a
kid
i think after 10 o'clock you can't be on
tick tock and oh by the way if you are
on tick tock after a certain amount of
time like 50 minutes or something you
can only watch science experiments and
other things really yeah they're not
[ __ ] around what they're they're
looking at um at a tick tock and social
media for children as a health hazard
china is that yes yeah it's a health
hazard which by the way in a lot of ways
it is
and so you know when you keep scrolling
the guy who invented the scroll thing
that's addictive
now in china after you do five there's a
pause there's like a five second pause
and then and then and then you do it
five more and they so they have all
these built-in ingenious things and they
were like we're not doing it well so
here's the big question youtube did this
censorship but here's the problem
the government could help you with this
but if you so if you're against the
government intervention you're still
being controlled by what corporations
who are making a fortune on the fact
that they can hijack your brain they can
they can jack your brain
and get tap into what it makes you makes
you addicted but even to elaborate on
that but you got to remember those those
the power companies like facebook and
instagram who are owned by the same mark
zuckerberg um his politics are the thing
that are going to be the agenda on those
platforms right so even so even if
you're anti-government but you're still
on social media those social medias are
only allow access and show what agenda
they want to push so either way it's
still a government well so their their
um their rebuttal to that is actually
there's a very very vibrant right-wing
community that uses social media i mean
they make a fortune doing that so so but
but it's really just that they don't
instagram all that like well he also
said that he goes it's they may be left
but they also make a fortune off the
capitalist system they're also crushing
it and and you're right the other
business yeah and they have so much
power but the question is do you allow
government to come in the way they did
with network tv network tv was regulated
by the government you couldn't have
swear words you couldn't have nudity you
could there was a stand that's called
standards and practices when i was on
mad tv the standards and practices would
when i had to do a thing with a a tissue
and i was always like that i was i was
doing i was doing blow and they were
like they standards in practice said it
looks like he's doing cocaine we can't
have them on tv so they were like just
act like you have a cult and i had to do
it a certain way so really yeah well we
always you should be seeing yeah yeah
i'm fine with that okay so but there are
a lot of people say oh you're getting in
the way of freedom of speech uh but when
it affects the health of the young and
it does
but there's a right-wing group that says
i'm not letting the government do it
okay but guess what it's gonna happen no
matter what right it's gonna happen no
matter what right so those things you're
against gonna happen no matter what
correct it's already happening you're
already don't act like we're not being
controlled you want to be controlled by
zuckerberg and bezos and all and tim
cook and all those guys they have a job
to do they're going to figure something
out you can do that or you have a
standard that the government sets you
know i'm i'm a i'm a pretty i'm a
libertarian kind of guy in a lot of ways
but listen we're getting to a point
where what are we going to do if this
[ __ ] is this it can't be the wild west
you got this is the very how's it going
like how so so are you happy where we're
at right now everybody's happy exactly
society's happy how's suicide how's
mental health going yeah how's that
going how's the diction how are you
funny and we know this isn't going to
get better so you want to just i know
i'm i'm with you freedom of choice all
that i'm with you but how's things going
are we happy with it right no
we did it
it's only get worse we know that
i i think i think that there are a lot
of ideas that that could really save us
that way and also we'll get there also
misinformation though the idea that you
can you are getting [ __ ] on both
ends that is pushing people further into
their ease so lebron
did lebron elbowed him yeah lebron
evolved i feel like he's getting i saw
this though right yeah i saw him do you
think he did it on purpose
here's my question is he is he
on edge because he's taking so much [ __ ]
about the china stuff no watch watch i
don't think this
let me know what you think
oh no he didn't mean to do that no
bro that looks like it's on purpose yeah
go back go back i don't think he meant
to cut his eye like that i think he's
trying to yeah i think he was just
trying to push them off
yeah that's a [ __ ] hit though like i
don't think his intentions were to like
[ __ ] dude's eye up no but watch it watch
me
dude it took so many people to hold him
back yeah look at westbrook
westbrook is ready to fight oh bro no
watch he he is again
so watch the
it was a big man trying to get out of
here
all those look at all the the little
white guys trying to stop him oh they
they start falling because they can't uh
they can't hold him that's a giant man
yeah he's very upset
why uh because he runs back at them look
at him oh my god
who's he trying to get at he's all of
them he want anybody
westbrook was that look how maddie but
he goes after him one more time
oh really yeah
he breaks free again uh-huh peace man
he was looking at my [ __ ] eye because
he because he because he walks up he
goes all right all right i'll leave i'll
leave all of you all right cool all
right cool
i'm good i'm good i'm good hold him back
in here
[Applause]
what's lebron james doing here are they
talking are they talking
i think
yeah oh someone got trapped yeah and
then wes look at westwood
yeah wow
i feel like stewart might beat the [ __ ]
out of lebron look at lebron
i think lebron was trying to be cool
like yo my bad let me see i want to see
if he is
he broke free into the tunnel yeah
you'll see here that was the funniest
part when he was like all right i'm
leaving he goes
out
is he trying to go around that's what it
seems like right
my favorite part is that all right i'm
good i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good
he's just wanted a [ __ ] punch
i can't imagine lebron's very tough
uh
i wouldn't he's been famous since he was
12. yeah i don't think yeah i don't
think he's got fed he's definitely still
competitive though i mean he is but like
yeah that's true i don't think yeah i
don't think he's trying to fight nobody
that guy would have beat the [ __ ] on
lebron
like that guy's so much tougher than
lebron
caught me
you are in every facet i'm not yeah no
i'm not don't say i'm casual why you
keep calling casual like this because
those people yeah he's big and strong
and he's so athletic i don't talk that
way he's so happy i don't talk that way
i talk like this no no i don't i think i
would [ __ ] i'll fight you now because
that guy didn't grow up like lebron like
the name of the tough guy
yeah name's the toughest guy you know
yeah he's just too much fun you've been
treated like
everyone takes care of your dirty work
yeah like you're not going to be tough
you're not looking to that guy's hungry
that guy wanted a piece yeah that guy's
yeah worth a billion dollars you cut me
in that guy's on space jam two right
he's got him he's got a lot
i think i think lebron was trying to
just push him off me too don't think so
i think yeah i don't think he was
i don't i don't think lebron was like
i'm gonna [ __ ] feel him here and you
go get the [ __ ] off man no i think he
mentioned that
i don't think he meant to [ __ ] up i bet
lauren was like oh [ __ ] yeah i think
lebron's a really nice guy yeah he's
trying to be cool
now if it was michael jordan jordan
jordan wouldn't jordan wouldn't be
saying sorry he'd just be like no well
if this is my if this is the early 90s
knowing we got a jacket yeah yeah
part of the game it was crazy how rough
that game was it was crazy that's how it
should be to be honest like the 90s was
nuts
detroit and stuff they're just beating
the [ __ ] out of those guys
what else you got jen
uh we talked about this on below the
belt but we didn't get to i didn't get
to show you this part so this is jon
jones claiming that he's sober for 60
days
yeah so here's his post and it's exactly
what he says here
be
be sober minded be watchful your
adversary the devil prowls around like a
roaring lion seeking someone to devour
my family my life my career could have
been over i thought it happened in las
vegas but god had other plans for me see
they sobering counting god had nothing
to do with you hitting your wife my man
a lot of things wrong with this but so
mike bond from uh mmajunkie
he wrote this
his arrest happened 58 days ago though
so even though it's like a couple days
few days but it's just kind of like
you know yeah he's just wait you're 60
days and then yeah yeah exactly it just
makes you more
goddamn
people are just and i'm sure everyone
can't you can't hit women dude yeah
that's when he lost everyone at that i
mean and get so many chances that was
that was the one that i was talking
about being a badass fighter i saw about
a woman i was talking about john someone
who's very high up in the ufc
he was just like think how much money
that guy's missed out on with all the
[ __ ] he's done in his life think
about the millions and millions of
dollars the nike endorsement the big
fights everything it's so weird man dude
it's so weird it's weird you know so
much it's a 50 million abuse problem
it's a major drug self-sabotage and
psychological he's not yeah yeah
i've seen way too much intervention man
part of what makes him maybe part of
what makes him such a [ __ ] badass is
is is that same engine yeah what brings
you down brings you up you know
you know him you knew him pretty damn
well didn't you or i didn't know him
that well i might train with him i never
hung out with him
but yeah see i don't know if it's that
recklessness that makes him so gifted
knock on i think that recklessness is a
such a cloud on his talent yeah like
that's not what makes him special yeah
at all it makes him a [ __ ] idiot
right i think how good he would be if he
didn't have all that
what what um
who is he going to fight now is it what
is his status now where is he
i mean
who knows yeah
he's waiting for the i think the winner
of cyril gone from yeah so he wants to
move to heavyweight and then he's going
to talk he's definitely moved to
heavyweight he's just waiting for the
ufc to figure that out and then ufc has
to figure this [ __ ] out what happens
with his wife he's going to say are they
they're going to be silent he's not
pressing charges so it'll just go away
pretty much go away yeah pretty much and
you do you see the video that football
player [ __ ] up his wife oh my god no
yeah it was bad there's like a
linebacker i think for the jets and the
falcons these are pretty bad
we don't want to watch on here i don't
know it's impossible to see it's it's
heartbreaking yeah dude he throws her
into a tv
and then picks slams her body slams her
in front of her five-year-old child yeah
oh my god so she records it and my take
away from it was like god what she's
such a badass because she's not freaking
out but then my girl was telling me i
guess on her instagram she was like a
lot of people were saying how calm and
collected i was she goes trust me inside
i was screaming for help but i didn't
want to scare the kid more like if i
start freaking out the babies
she goes so
wow she said she's been doing this for a
while now
it started when she got pregnant ah real
piece of dude what a real piece of [ __ ]
and now he's out on base right here
no you didn't knock her out no this one
here so now four days ago you got ray
rice no no here this one yeah i can't
link here i just don't want to click on
it oh yeah so now what happens to him is
he out of the nfl yeah he's got to be
right i don't think i think he's been
out
oh
so this is uh law enforcement oh yeah
they arrested him they caught him hiding
at a friend's house in florida where is
he 30 years old former footballer he's a
running back
what a [ __ ] bad guy man
and then he just posts bail they let him
out that's his girlfriend right there
yeah
says her and her family are not safe
yeah my thing is you do that to a woman
and they just post bail you out on the
street
it's [ __ ] insane you you would have a
court-ordered protection though you know
that's nuts
some kind of a corridor thing he's got
some kind of an anger issue [ __ ]
whatever it is man piece of [ __ ]
zero tolerance in front of the kid um
nuts that's a very dangerous man
wait till that kid grows those men
oh when you see the weight what he does
to her oh dude it's it's a it's a very
very men like that killer i i watch [ __ ]
on world star man i saw that like holy
[ __ ] this is bad and and uh
he's [ __ ] good luck getting a job
after that and everything else what's he
doing what does he do for a living
i guess he has a pension um
ryan hall wants to beat him up i do too
yeah
nothing get me back in the knockdown but
if you give me him i'll do it
yeah yeah i'd beat the [ __ ]
yeah yeah
i'll be in your corner just squeeze him
just [ __ ] no just just box his
[ __ ] face up i'd knock him out i
don't want to make it quick i knocked
him out
you wanted a lingering a lingering
beating i would throw him like you threw
his girl and not just knock him out
yeah that'd be cool
all right let's go
yeah
oh this one i thought was awesome
a nine-year-old girl
saw her mom
get her purse almost snatched and the
guy actually pushed her to the ground
and she started punching the guy's face
the little girl little nine-year-old
girl damn girl
here's a video of it yep okay it's a
really bad video but you can see here so
they're right here this guy wants to
steal the mom's purse
and watch the little girl come out from
here boom starts punching in the face
and scares him off no
oh sh he got away but the the report
says that she chased him for like four
houses down but he got away the little
girl chased him and the cops you know
gave her like an award and all that
stuff too here that's awesome
that's him
they caught the guy out right yeah
that's a little girl
a little badass man yeah
what a doll that's so cool man oh cool
chabella guy on the far right has your
same pants
[Laughter]
that's similar you have the same pants
that's very cool
kung fu movies where the master is
wearing that oh
i love those [ __ ] pants me too i love
those pants that's a he's a comfortable
man right there when you're older [ __ ]
you those old shaolin movies where the
voices are dubbed yes dude those are the
best sweatshirts how about the poor lady
with her eyes closed like could you post
a different i need to wear i need some
i'm gonna start wearing sweat track
suits maybe i'll start wearing tracks oh
my god pull off track suits brian yeah
real talk right
like an adidas one yes cool
what do i get i need i need help on your
black and a boy
get a blue one so some color photoshop
steve made another photoshop of you and
this is amazing i think yeah
[Laughter]
so that's the attraction
photoshop
don't you normally do photoshops
[Laughter]
that's so good dude bro that is so good
wow that's really exactly what my hair
is i was contemplating another hair
transplant that'll make three that'll
make daddy's had some procedures three
procedures on my face
because i got a hair transplant lid
stuff i feel like they're here they're
getting so good now that's what i'm
saying i'm gonna go talk i know yeah
they're killing the game that would be
the time it'd be kind of cool right hell
yeah dude how much does it cost libra
likes i don't know 13 grand six grand
i don't know how much hey like this yeah
it's not 13 grand you did earlier yeah
in the 90s
i'm not going to turkey you're first to
market no they do it here remember that
company even offered
the company hit us up and was like yeah
that's a wig one right no uh-uh they do
the turkish thing but it's here in l.a
oh really yeah yeah
i'm gonna get one maybe it's beautiful
it'd be fun shout out to photoshop steve
yeah yeah he's amazing he's really good
he's good
damn
i need it but do you have who do i what
company do i get a track suit at that's
the question
puma
because you wear those adidas a lot yeah
you can't wear a puma tracksuit with
that yeah
but like you do adidas yeah let me just
get you some new sambas
he has track suits they all make tracks
yeah it might be tracks you've got for a
while but like you got to go with the og
yeah adidas if you're going to do
tracksuit really
okay
it's got to be a little loose
oh
not too loose you look ridiculous yeah
if it was loose
be some run dmc
yeah gotta walk around with a boom box
after that yeah no i'm gonna i'm gonna
start doing that
yeah the ladder suits one or the other
but i think it's got to be the same
thanks for sending me that picture
yesterday oh of jojo yeah
so chappelle's hall pass is jojo
no my girl did not give me all that [ __ ]
i like doing the whole point i like jojo
the girl i'm a cow [ __ ] i'm a cow no no
no no no no no
jojo what was her main hit two little
two yeah too little too late get out
right she's had like two hits but she's
back now
she's back now i saw her in concert she
was you got the amas on the red carpet
that's right i screenshot that uh
chappelle i said your girl
is popping too she's so hot that's my
milk of magnesia yep she's so hot
chappelle's white guy
she just look at her yeah
the ama she's a
fabulous singer though really really
[ __ ] talented
singer
she's going to press her about mental
health why is this pop no no
yeah
no she's the whole article i follow i
follow her i know what she talks about
is that her family concert yeah yeah
yeah that's the picture
i screenshot that and senator said your
girl is brought the heat tonight
yeah banging jesus i know that's growing
up pretty nutty
i saw her at crossroads yeah very
interesting she's growing up i remember
her like when she was like this
christian good looking at her no the way
the weight changes that's what she
looked like back
could you stop talking about my
celebrity crush like that dog naughty in
your pants
it's nutty bar look at her she's a
little kitty no she's cute i'm telling
you type in jojo mental health jen i'm
telling you she's not going to tour
you're not following you didn't even
know she was at the amaze dude i have to
send it to you
there you go mental health
and what and then go to new york you go
jojo opens up people magazine
teen vogue depression anxiety i'm
telling you dude she's got a crazy story
what's the story well just like uh she
was signed to this regular sure she
couldn't make any music for like i
couldn't get out they locked her down
yeah heard it
that's not a crazy story
when you're a fan of her it's a crazy
story no britney has a [ __ ] crazy
story
saying he he's got a little crush on her
and he knows no but she's killing her oh
she got an antidote you feel her power
and he tried to stop you bro
[ __ ]
not on my watch
back to now he's like thanos with this
[ __ ]
oh you're just not in your pocket
yeah i don't know where i'm going yeah i
went sorry in concert like 2013. my
girl's 32. uh
i'm old guy and she said to me we were
dating she goes if you yeah i go i go if
i was 40 you'd be out she was if you
were 40 i wouldn't let you out of my
sight she goes i wish you were younger
it was always the case i wish you were
younger and then
we
she's all brian you're her time machine
it's like what
i guess napoleon died do you know what i
was i knew i was in trouble with her
because i i just i started to [ __ ]
really fall for her but i remember we
had we got a little busy before i had to
leave got a little busy it was like it
was like i don't know 12 in the
afternoon i had to leave and i i just it
was it was
special right
i just get this text i get this text it
just says my [ __ ] man
and i went
oh i like this girl i i remember when
you i remember when you [ __ ] fell in
love with joe yeah because joe joe my
wife at the time said i like that girl i
said why she goes look at the way she
looks at the children like she was such
a mom before she had kids yeah
and you you know you were you were you
were hungry eyes girls girls liked you
you had your and you you text me
just this one thanks you go
i like joe bro
out of nowhere i like joe bro
well i told joe on our first date i said
you know you're meant to have kids yeah
she's like what yep that's a you're my
dad i remember all of it yeah i remember
all of it and you and then you she was
she was classy right yeah and you're
like hey let's get busy what i know but
she goes she goes she looks he goes i
don't know who the [ __ ] you think i am
and i don't know who you're used to
dealing with but this isn't what that
mess
hater damn hater
what else you got jim uh just one more
yeah on this dick yeah that's the first
time i saw this damn take it easy
seminal moments in our relationship good
you got to be
take it easy because he's talking about
jojo he just wants to connect with this
girl you're talking about yeah i'm
trying to tell you about the concert or
that time
no no we talked about our girl she
probably don't say [ __ ] about his
girlfriend yeah she's amazing
one more time hides his dick from us
yeah that's awesome yeah all i want to
do is i'm a prude [ __ ]
you haven't seen it either never and
he's on the road with me i know he
showers at weird times
he's that weird kid
you have an anteater huh you have an
antidote yeah i've said that before oh i
didn't know i knew it yeah
why did you say that you're comfortable
with saying that you're [ __ ] so
you're uncut uncut yeah the way god
intended to be okay the way god intended
supposed to be better
is that what they say it looks weird i
don't give a [ __ ]
you know it looks different chin you're
uncircumcised aren't you yeah i told you
this many times yeah said it plenty of
times that that wizards [ __ ] mine
looks nice
pull it out
yeah pull it out here you're doing
pretty well down there my girl didn't
know i was uncircumcised when we you
know first had sex because because the
headphones dude that happened to me too
the head pops out so this is a
turtleneck on it just it looks like a
regular yeah
it does
pull it back
when it gets erect it yeah you don't
know the difference yeah it has a turkey
knife call it a [ __ ] turkey
there's more there's yeah it adds
thickness too just letting you know it
has a thickness it has a slinky on it's
neck
you guys uh get ant eaters over there no
no no yeah you guys don't know i was
born in korea though so most times yeah
most of them are most uh asians like a
lot of asians dude i'm the only one out
of all my siblings uh my brother's that
yeah here's the town now
that's for everybody
does everybody know why
why if you're for example muslim or
you're jewish you get circumcised
because it's a religious thing no do you
know where it comes from no it's really
weird it's a religion it doesn't make
sense it's so old it's so old school i
didn't want to circumcise my kids so so
so it became in the in when i was
growing up like a lot of now the reason
christians in the united states got
circumcised was there was an idea that
was healthier that it led to less
infection and all that they've since i
think debunked that but it's like
self-cleaning right cool yeah but but
but
primarily in nazi germany they make you
pull your pants down if you were
circumcised you were a jew you went to
the concentration camp right so even if
you said had blonde hair you had to you
know show that you take out but why is
it but so so
it from it's from the old testament
it's so weird and moses showed his
subservience to god by cutting his penis
it's a religious thing now when they do
it it's because
like in pornos when you grow up
like the dicks are never they never have
hoods on them ever very rarely right but
but so now it's like more like but a
rabbi a rabbi commits the the the skills
it commits well now it's a filipino
nurse but yeah but did this say 700.
costs us 790 to cut our [ __ ] but that's
why that's why the rabbi
i think he call he's called the moyle
it's such an old-school tradition it
makes no [ __ ] sense but god gave him
circumstances
upon the biblical patriarch abraham i'm
sorry his descendants and their slaves
as a token of the covenant concluded
with him by god for all generations an
everlasting covenant i'm going to cut my
dick as a as a subservient so abraham
thus is coming served by two judaism and
islam of the abraham how insane so
that's [ __ ] crazy it makes no sense
it well it's it's from the bible whereas
the biggest fight about it out of my out
of my out of my washington one no i
didn't want him to get certain sex
because i know it's this old school
[ __ ] oh got it i don't believe in it
out of out of my subservience to you i
will cut my force
isn't that crazy don't you wish you got
a hood i wish i had a little [ __ ]
like ram air i don't know i grew up just
knowing most people that i you know but
such an old school thing like makes no
sense to cut that
god made it for a reason to have a hood
jen that happened to me though uh i
hooked up with a girl and she uh she
asked for her later on she asked for a
dick pic
yeah and then i sent it and she goes
you're not circumcised i was like
yeah
oh you didn't pull back the the knight
and shred armor yeah i mean but it was i
mean it was dark i sent it with the
anteater
yeah why not you did really yeah i don't
know i just wanted to get all of this
yeah
all right it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be cleaner with the hood on
it
i heard the opposite yeah people that's
just so lame
look it up you can see it it is it's
like you start to clean the inside
that's like washing it it's like washing
your armpits or something it's like yeah
it's yeah but you don't have to clean it
because yeah you got to clean your dick
regardless
you don't clean your dick normally right
right
yeah no no it's not like this like flat
it's like it's just like it's like that
that's it i grew up overseas i've seen a
lot of uncircumcision no there's i'm
sure there's like crazy ones yeah
i'm sure i'm sure you guys have bigger
hoods than others yeah but oh there's
some big hoods out there is it
straight-up
it just closes down a wizard's
everything i'm not going to bring it up
right my computer has so many viruses
already hang it up come on
yeah
that sounds like a porn parody of on
caught gems uncut [ __ ] oh it's out there
wait let's go so uncut
uncircumcised penises yeah just
uncertain large on circumstances if you
put mars guys [ __ ] you'll get you'll get
some serious large uncircumcised penises
can we do like the pros and cons there
you go buddy there you go spell penis is
wrong i spelled on circumcised
all
wrong
um well that's we see like my [ __ ] don't
look like that
no there you go that one what's your
skin right there
yeah this is like that's insane there
you go that's insane there you go they
don't they don't do like that anymore
that's probably like in cucumbers yeah
this is crazy yeah that's crazy yeah
i'm sorry i just it looks nothing like
i'm sorry
but these are just like
these are crazy examples
those are crazy there's more like this
one more like mine
that's a big deal
is that stevie
that one there this is downloading free
gay college men but you see you see the
one with the hair on it okay the
yeah that one that's the one the
download gate college thing though no i
know you don't click on download i'm
just saying
that's a congratulations on that
it just looks like you got eaten at the
top
it looks like it's missing something
looks like it's like you got bit off you
don't see a lot of it do you i think
it's better to have that
that's
that root i want to look at who that guy
is so we can shake his hand
this guy's just normal yeah
but there you go oh my god
what i saw oh
dude
i haven't seen a black person
uncircumcised before i've never knew i
didn't know that was a thing yeah it's
good yeah yeah right here
well there you go right here
that one's encased in a thin skin all
right lord that's a piece there's like
two different ones two different penises
god damn congratulations on it okay are
we good with this yeah the circumcised
stuff is it's you you just thought you
had we ever had a podcast where it
didn't end at least in some
dictatorships i don't know how we got
sometimes
here and oh and then uh
because you've never seen his piece
and i said i bet he's on circumcised and
he said yeah i've said that before which
is new to me
i've said yeah
me and chen talked about it on on the
part
that's you not on his episode no i'm
talking about here
this episode
well this has been king of this thing
does he get ashy like you have to lotion
yeah i get ashy [ __ ] get one
dick does yes
i don't get asked yeah i get actually
you don't get actually get that yeah i
get it yeah you have to lotion it up
yeah bro there you go i thought it
doesn't self-lubricate too though
why not isn't that what the trunk is for
self lubricant now
it's literally it's just like your skin
it's there's nothing every time and
every time you gotta go shoot yourself
you're just asking questions
the chiseled one it's like you guys have
antlers you know like i don't know i
don't have antlers a man can't ask
questions you could ask questions yeah
let you know yeah not all right well i'm
on circumcised and no you are
circumcised
and chappelle backflip uncircumcised
lacy we're uh bringing our big dicks to
everett washington everett theater one
night only this saturday november 27th
then dania florida which is fort
lauderdale uh improv out there december
30th through january
first bring in the new year with your
thick friends and chappelle's big
uncircumcised dick's gonna be there at
both shows fantastic he's gonna do a
backflip and get it out or they'll just
land
oh boca raton december third i'm at the
laughing spree comedy testament he's in
florida more than i would like a little
bit too much about that flight's too far
a little too much and then kansas city
missouri improv december 17th or or are
we doing companion then who knows you
never know i have to cancel you never
know oklahoma city oklahoma bricktown
comedy club i wish i was bringing new
year's in in oklahoma city it's one
minute bro that's my favorite club
really oh yeah wait i can't wait for you
to meet that security guard december
30th hey you fundamental aoe
january 1. salt lake city utah wise guys
january 6th 7th and 8th specan
washington spokane comedy club january
20 21 22.
there it is oh i'm excited i'm closing
out my year headlining uh dc
san jose improv december 1st one night
only 8 pm show get your tickets boom
boom boom and also check out my podcast
chappelle's world who's on it this week
uh khalil roundtree hell yeah
yeah
yeah
you guys are uh brothers from a
different oh my god they're the same guy
yeah we were sitting down talking about
saving for people but man it was
literally like the huh we're like the
same dude yeah it was kind of crazy it
was one can like one can skateboard and
one can knock people the [ __ ] out it was
the same person is he on circumstance
he should actually
when you were talking about you feel
weird next to people yeah
he was he was someone that i like i feel
like a piece of [ __ ] standing next to
him
he's awesome yeah he lost 300 [ __ ]
pounds and what's he fighting at 85 yeah
no 205 oh shut up how tall is he uh he's
taller than me six one maybe yeah that's
a nightmare that's a nightmare oh dude
he's a stud great guy yeah great great
so nice yeah one of the nicest yeah i
gave him a ride home uh right to his
hotel and [ __ ] he's from l.a we were
chopping it up we were blaring uh
hardcore music and stuff dude you gave
him a ride homeless in the punk rock
yeah
that's cool
all right kids oh and uh thick boy the
the thick uh friday sold out we're
restocking for uh black friday
this friday we're restocking the camo
workout gear and some of the jerseys
will restock to print them as we [ __ ]
speak so black friday this friday mark 9
a.m pacific you always use the squad
9am pacific uh thinkboy.com we're
restocking the store and we also have a
sale going on too for black friday
that's this friday thinkboy.com all
right kids everett see you this saturday
we love you guys let's do it